Shale development may be the key to the US
remaining the sole superpower for the next
two generations.
Energy is one of the keys to global political
power.
The US is in a great position with regard
to energy. We have shale, we have gas, we
have oil, and more importantly we have competitive
markets—anyone can develop them. Around
the world, our rivals are in much worse positions.
Everybody knows about Russia’s problems,
Venezuela’s problems, but even China—thought
to be an economic powerhouse—is far behind
the United States. The US is the number one
producer of energy in the world, and China
is now the number one importer. The reason
for that is China doesn’t allow competition.
It doesn’t allow private property rights.
As a result, production of coal and crude
oil are down requiring more imports even if
economic growth slows. So while US gas production
is soaring, Chinese gas imports are soaring.
In 2008 at the height of the financial crisis,
it seemed as if US global was fading away.
Now we’re much sought after as an ally,
cooperation in energy, trade, US energy production
being shipped overseas.
While the US will remain committed to the
Middle East, we don’t need to be dependent
anymore on Middle Eastern energy producers
like Saudi Arabia and Iran. In contrast, China
is now the largest importer from the Middle
East and could become enmeshed in the same
kind of problems in the Middle East that have
plagued the United States for the last forty
years.
There are plenty of risks to this. Here in
the United States we could just decide not
to produce as much energy as we have been.
We could do that for environmental reasons
or just for political reasons. In China, they
could return to a path of market reform making
the Chinese economy and energy sector much
stronger.
Even if everything works out the way we expect
in the US and China, other developments could
occur such as China moving closer to Russia,
threatened by the revitalization of American
power.
Seven years ago, Goldman Sachs predicted $200
a barrel oil. That turned out to be completely
wrong. What has also turned out to be completely
wrong is the inevitable decline of America
and the rise of China. In fact, the exact
opposite is occurring: the US is rising and
China is stagnating.